good morning John a few months ago I
made a video arguing that Elon Musk
misunderstood the challenges of content
moderation in social media and that I
figured he was quickly discovering as
nilai Patel has said that the main
product of a social media platform is
content moderation whether that's
recommendations or algorithmic feeds or
demoting and censoring hateful content I
think that I was right about that but
also that Elon was right about something
else that I totally missed and should
have seen I am a person who
professionally understands a large group
of people that's not the whole job but
it's a big piece of it like
understanding what people will like what
they are thinking about what they're
concerned about what they're worried
about what they're excited about Elon
Musk is absolutely right that his people
his audience are really worried about
something that they call Free Speech
this is not what I call free speech and
it is not what is protected by the First
Amendment but it is a thing and it's a
totally legitimate thing here it is
internet media platforms have a huge
influence on society and there are
people who work at those platforms who
we do not know know and thus cannot
trust who have a huge influence on what
is allowed on those platforms and what
is promoted and demoted that's real and
it's weird and it's worrying because
this is a lot of how people communicate
now now what Elon Musk said out loud
about this was if people want laws
preventing speech they'll pass laws
preventing speech and until that happens
Twitter should just allow all legal
speech that's what he said but what he
meant was somebody's going to be making
these subjective moderation decisions
and I don't trust them but I do trust
myself and a lot of other people trust
me too as I tweeted a few weeks ago a
lot of people who say they want free
speech actually just want to be the one
in charge of which speech is free I
thought elon's audience was going to get
super mad at him very quickly because it
would turn out that he would have to
continue making all these subjective
content moderation decisions because
Twitter still had to be a business that
was appealing to users and advertisers I
was totally wrong about this Elon Musk
doesn't need to change the content
moderation policies of Twitter in order
to satisfy his audience because this
isn't about policy it's about Vibes it's
not about the decisions it's about who
is making the decisions indeed so far he
hasn't changed any policies though I'm
not going to put it past it even the
ones that he was most upset about before
he was in charge and it seems mostly
like his audience isn't at all concerned
about that so elon's obviously feeling
very empowered so is his audience but
now we have the opposite problem his
people are happy everybody else is
either unhappy or at least concerned
because remember I just said this it was
never about the decisions it was about
The Vibes it was about who's making the
decisions and a lot of people are not
and will never be fans of Elon Musk
Twitter's previous management for all of
its failures did try to like listen to
people who were upset and then make a
decision that was thoughtful and
transparent but Elon is mostly just
gleefully antagonistic towards people
who don't agree with that and if those
people who've Twitter it just becomes an
eight dollar a month subscription to the
Elon Musk fan club and that's not a good
website however right now the opposite
is happening people are flocking to
Twitter specifically because of Elon
musk's erratic Behavior is the second
thing he was right about that I didn't
get people don't want Twitter to be
stable they want it to be reality TV
drama constantly unfolding before them
feeling important despite being mostly
inconsequential leaning into the
interesting
has been good for Twitter's growth but I
think it's been very bad for Twitter
internally and I think it's been bad for
advertising dollars and I have no idea
whether you can build a sustainable
business this way it seems like it would
be hard uh and there are a number of
challenges that Twitter will need to
overcome but what I do know is that
while Twitter only occasionally brings
me joy the awesome socks Club brings me
joy every single month you can get a
different pair of socks designed by a
different independent artist to deliver
to your door once a month free shipping
cancel anytime ankle socks or mid-calf
Crews now we're shipping out of the EU
so you don't have to worry about Customs
if you're in Europe I just want to make
this as easy a decision as possible the
socks are super comfy people will tell
you this they're all I wear anymore and
100 of the profit goes to decrease
maternal and child mortality in Sierra
Leone John I'll see you on Tuesday